[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
happy tuesday everyone it's great to see
joe mackey is on today
i wonder what he's been up to
well joe i had no idea you were such a
thrill seeker
no no not really not
well thank you for that all right so
it's no longer a border crisis it's an
unmitigated border disaster mega crisis
thousands upon thousands living under a
texas bridge and not in a good way
you know if this were spring break and
those who were partying undergrads the
outrage would be palpable it's a super
spreader event they're where are the
masks why aren't they six feet apart
what do they think this is the emmys
which raises the obvious question how
did it get this bad well it's simple the
media does its best not to cover bad
news when their guy is in office or in
delaware or wherever joe's wandered off
to in an open robe
his hands sticky from rocky road
remember it's not what they report on
it's what they emit that does the real
damage as long as democrats are in power
the media holds the reigns yes the
reigns we'll get to that
now fox covered the border under both
trump and biden and the fact is we'd all
be like biden and harris totally
clueless about the border if it weren't
for fox news's amazing coverage
if trump were in charge you can bet all
the networks would be covering it like
the kennedy assassination they'd be
patting themselves on the back with one
hand and doing god knows what with the
other
instead they buried this story like jill
biden does with a prevagen pill and
joe's morning scone
so it takes fox news to shame the crummy
media into doing their job
consider this more than 12 000 migrants
are packed in a refugee camp in america
a camp remember that phrase how the
media often predicted that donald trump
was going gonna put people in camps
they got the camps part right except it
took them to elect biden so they could
get the camps
just like that famous republican tyrant
fdr
and what do you hear from the media well
they're as quiet as joe in his 1pm nap
until now of course yeah in case you
wondered if there was a way to get the
media to finally care about the border
there is you flip it so that we
americans become the monsters then their
heads turn so fast they'll need a
chiropractor
so out comes the story that the border
patrol on horseback were whipping
haitians trying to enter the country yes
americans were whipping black people
again
just like the old days when democrats
were in charge
and so the media is now all over this
story spreading this unchecked manure
like a professional landscaper
they know if the story could be wielded
as a weapon against america they do it
whether it's true or not when it comes
to hating america the taliban has
nothing on these clowns
initially both the dhs secretary and the
border control chief explained that
those aren't whips
but reigns to control the horses which
may make sense it protects the horses
and the people closest to them but don't
tell that to the media who can only
react to images that inflame them
remember covington who needs contact
context when you have one inflammatory
moment here's a picture of a border
patrol on a horse in a stream
so how long before cnn accuses these
border patrol men of trying to drown
horses in the rio grande
now you know what it's been a while
since i rode a horse kentucky derby
2004.
i came in eighth
turns out you have to be on top of the
horse
but even i knew this story was kind of
odd mickey alcindor of pbs described the
border patrol as seemingly using whips
before asking gensaki if they should be
fired
seemingly just like pbs is seemingly a
news organization just because they have
three letters in their name
even if even if those letters stand for
pure
but i guess
it'll probably be bleeped at home but
you can figure out what the bs stands
for
but the suffering of 12 000 refugees
didn't matter until she found someone in
law enforcement to smear
yamiche it's all good questions we just
saw this footage it's horrible to watch
i just have to get more information on
it
april i don't i don't have more
information on it i've also seen the
video i can't imagine what the scenario
is where that would be appropriate oh i
can imagine the scenario
but enough about my golden girls fantasy
[Laughter]
in it i'm tied up and each one has a
writing crop
maybe i should have just stopped with i
have a fantasy
remember the good old days when
reporters actually used their brains and
their feet and ran down a story
and neither do i now they just see
something online and that's their source
it's a common thing ignore a big story
because those images undermine your
political side but embrace one image
because they can then frame it any way
they want so run with the image ask
questions later call it covington101
all right people we're journalists we've
already reached our conclusions let's go
find some evidence
well i found some shocking photos and i
checked all our sources instagram and
tick tock
oh that's not good enough better double
check twitter too
gotcha here's what i found it's a lady
yelling at a cat
presumably about the wage gap oh not bad
oh make sure the cat identifies as a cat
oh and there's this
this is an elderly man
he's cold he's alone at brazil he's some
kind of war hero maybe a vietnam vet
pretty good definitely looks homeless
with that haircut certainly not somebody
who owns multiple homes
and
this one
a bunch of people under a bridge
that's not news
and so this whip story also snagged abc
who prior to this didn't give a crap
about the border crisis
there are alarming images from the texas
border tonight the white house pressed
on them today calling the images
horrific what were some border patrol
agents doing
look at what these agents are doing yeah
it's called their job mirror try it
sometime
turns out
turns out he's as shallow as a
supermodel in a kiddie pool but he is
handsome
and finally the second dumbest man on
cnn
i'll let you figure out the first
goes all in with the slavery analogy
we really are in the throes in this
country of figuring out who we are
and what we're about
and
i was taken aback
by
a single image
that should make you pay attention to a
problem as an image
to me it does smack of a bygone era
of slavery
aided by reports of people being beaten
whether with a riding crop or the rains
most likely
you may be drawn to the desperation of
the man trying to escape
others
in the desperation of keeping our
borders safe
of what i believe the former president
tried to depict as a brown menace at our
border
none of this
none of it
is
new
and it is not isolated
yes none of this is new if you mean the
hot garbage
spewing forth from your gaping lying pie
hole
and i don't blame i don't blame this
jackass for not covering the border he
was too busy defending his corrupt
brother and trying to save his job on a
network hooked up to a respirator and in
grave condition
don't let his brother near the network
so instead of focusing on the thousands
of haitians living under a bridge chris
grafts hold of one outrageous image
like it was his favorite plastic
dumbbell and i don't mean don lemon
i guess we should be
i guess we should be grateful for a
liberal media finally paying attention
to this crisis that they helped create
by getting biden elected but it has
nothing to do with compassion or
journalism they just found a way to do
the story so it's not about the white
house but instead evil law enforcement
it's about americans trying to do their
jobs because the administration and the
media they won't do theirs and now you
watch the hacks in government suddenly
changing their tune
images have come out of border patrol
agents with communication immigrants so
my question to you do you think that's a
humane way to treat migrants
you are assuming facts
that have not yet been determined to
ensure control uh of the horse long
reigns are used but we are going to
investigate the facts to ensure uh that
the situation is as we understand it to
be and if it's anything different we
will respond accordingly any
mistreatment or abuse of a migrant is
unacceptable
is against border patrol policy one
image
so you see my point it would be one
thing if the press or majorcas had cared
about the crisis while we cared about
the crisis all that footage we showed
you know if they followed this story and
the government had acted we wouldn't
even be discussing this story because it
wouldn't exist
fact is this is just about seizing a
story that suits them they found a
boogeyman a cop on a horse and that's
all they needed to pretend to care when
they really truly don't give a damn at
all
let's welcome tonight's guests
he always knows where his laptop is
philanthropist and executive vp of the
trump organization eric trump
she's so bright someone else in cat is
too hungover to look at her
author of the new book no one will miss
her cat rosenfield
he's the man of a thousand faces and all
of them terrify comedian joe mackey
and
opposites attract it's a nice way of
saying her husband never burned down a
reform school fox news contributor cat
tip
all right eric to the important
questions how do you think my sock
choice is today i look i like your socks
greg
elephants on my socks you know elephants
yeah it's nice yeah i could see the
elephants but i don't know mine are very
stripey and dotty i feel a little weird
wearing them today i thought i'd get
that out of the way because i noticed
you were staring at me and one staring
at the man warning what the hell is
wrong with this person a little bit yeah
that's okay what do you why do you think
the media is now ignored this crisis
until now well it's horrible and by the
way the hypocrisy is insane craig last
week the biden administration droned a
family of ten that's right they took a
hellfire missile and shot it at a family
and then they lied about it but yet they
want to demonize law enforcement who's
riding a horse they ignore that story by
killing a family of ten including seven
children
and then they throw law enforcement
under
you know the boat
literally because they can't control
a problem that they created it's
horrible yeah it's absolutely horrible
it's amazing to me cat cat number one
you'll be cat number two i mean i was
first yes but in your life yeah go ahead
yeah but she's a guest
so she gets number one and you get
number two yep okay or you can go sit in
your room
all right
i don't want to get any back talk from
you anymore
[Laughter]
no seriously she has her own phone
she has car privileges and yet she's
constantly here complaining
too much advanced notice for the car
though i like to live a little more free
spirited than that but it's not like you
even drive the car
not well i know
cat one i apologize for cat two
so here we have i love that's chris
cuomo thing drives me crazy because you
have like months and months of all of
these disturbing
visions images on the border and then he
goes all i need is one image to make the
whole story as he denied everything else
why do you think how can he not see this
blind spot i mean this is a thing you
know this is a problem with how news is
reported across the board there's this
desire to find this tribal narrative as
if you know americans are too stupid to
understand the nuances of a crisis like
what's happening at the border unless
there's a villain that they can hate
right and i don't know it it makes me
crazy i really would like for the people
who are responsible for
reporting this for disseminating this
information to the public and for
leading the conversation about it to
just stick with the truth because the
truth is horrifying enough it's very
upsetting you know we could just use the
truth yeah we could use the truth joe
i always say that to you yeah when i
leave for work in the morning i spin a
yarn you know that yeah you do spin
those yarns
and you make a mean sweater too yeah
so anyway
any thoughts cross your
strange and twisted mind why is it that
reporters are are they lazy or is it
something biological that they they see
an image and they run with it and
they're taught they're taught about
context but they forget it if it
fulfills their cognitive bias it fits
the narrative i was going to mention the
drone strike and how they ignored that
narrative after the fact but eric beat
me to the punch and i was also going to
talk about how this problem's been
ignored by the media for a very long
time every time i hear the estimate of
how many illegal immigrants are in the
country it's 11 to 22 million
that doesn't inspire confidence when the
gap is 11 million people yes
because that means you could deport
theoretically 11 million people and
there would either be zero people in the
country illegally or 11 million people
i'm sorry i'm all messed up from that uh
uh that jet ski yeah
amazing
it's amazing how long you've been doing
that oh six or seven days
yeah you look like you've been doing it
for years i'm a good athlete you really
are you really are no it's amazing i i i
it was i i've been watching that on loop
uh the hot tub cat two um any final
thoughts on this very interesting story
yeah i did have a thought and i haven't
heard it anywhere else and i haven't
said it to anyone else so why not try it
out on the show that millions of people
watch yes um i was looking at this and
obviously we only ever talk about this
when there is a crisis and congress
should have already been doing something
about this this is their job this
doesn't happen in a system that's not
totally messed up but i did have a
thought also i thought that was the
thought no i have another one
you lied for two thoughts okay this
thought is um do any of these people
they uh do they want jobs
we have so many open jobs that's true i
am like look i am
you know there's so many job openings i
want to take them if jessica from new
jersey is too good to work at a
restaurant uh these people there's legal
ways for refugees to be able to work in
this country and a lot of these people
have seen some
okay they're not gonna call out because
their boyfriend broke up with them right
the third time good point restaurants
are struggling there's job openings no
one will take but again the entire
system is too messed up and backlogged
to allow that but why not let some of
these people work
you're talking about fixing a process
that makes people who who want to come
and work here yes replace people who
aren't working here yes yes i mean i
would i would vote for that but you know
what i don't think anybody would want to
work at a restaurant right now where
they're going to be accused of being
racist because you're for you you ask
for a vaccine card
well i don't know well jessica can keep
working on her fashion blog and people
who want jobs can take the job that was
a cheap stab at jessica and her family
well you know what you don't know how
bad it is all right